on allait au festival d'avignon et on
visite sans commencent à comparer je lui
dit cherry regarde comme c'est beau et
là je dis mais regarde les voûtes et là
je lève la tête enthousiates regarde
comme c'est beau et bam j'ai à peine le
temps de la voir une énorme fientes de
pigeons qui me tombe sur la gueule comme
si le gars temps des eaux de la voûte
que j'arrive et là j'en avais plein être
étonné été touché 1 mais partout parce
que comme javel cclat la tête levée
c'est pas tomber que là ça a dit nice
est partout j'en avais partout et le
problème qu'on avait c'est qu'on n'avait
pas beaucoup d'argent on logeait dans le
camping qui est très loin sur une île
mais bon on peut trouver un petit boulot
mais on n'avait pas de mouchoir on était
il est superbe on n'avait pas de
mouchoir moi j'avais moi parce que quand
il fait pas beau vous avez des mouchoirs
le rapport et ça m'est arrivé une
deuxième fois à paris
non mais oui à côté de chez moi et on
m'a dit qu'effectivement on en a dit
qu'effectivement les pigeons sentait
leur cible non ils repèrent là où ils
peuvent fientes et claque mais pourquoi
les pigeons au choix dispose j'en sais
rien mais possède que ce soit lui même